welcome to the brave souls here here in
person get to see this thrilling report
firsthand we are here to talk about
bake-off three if you've already
forgotten what we were doing was
developing the best relation extraction
systems we possibly could a highly
multi-class problem and we are looking
at f-14 to determine the best systems
histogram of the results from about a
hundred different models here compared
to where our simple bag of words feature
Iser baseline was from the homework you
can see this is very exciting
most of us managed to beat that baseline
that's great we've been doing this thing
where we use our VSM code to analyze the
code variables we used to see if we
could find any trends in this case it's
really noisy so we're gonna skip this
and instead look at something that's a
little bit more anecdotal but we did we
went through the top 15 and the bottom
15 systems and tried to draw out
patterns of what were some of the
commonalities and the top performing
systems I think the the biggest the
biggest trend is caring about your
features seems to be a lot more
productive than caring about your model
or your modeling architecture so the top
systems actually we can see here 66% of
the top systems used just a simple
logistic regression the other 33% used a
random forest and really it was in just
the the the wealth the the voluminous of
feature risers where that really
distinguished the top systems so it was
kind of fun scanning through this code
because it's like I'm playing Mad Libs
with the words left right middle
directional pause by Graham and trigram
so you can kind of combine like pick
three combine them and do that ten times
and you'll have like a really good
system and definitely combining
different kinds of features was was the
biggest kind of
brought us the biggest lift so on
average the top 15 systems had five
feature eyes errs compared to the bottom
ones which generally just had one and so
I think that that shows that you can
kind of get along a get pretty far by
thinking about what are the inputs to
the model so one example the very top
system congratulations to this group so
this you can see here we have I think
this is like 10 different to 10
different feature risers this group did
include some glove features as well and
this kind of on repeated runs brought
them in just above our second place who
also had a got a nice long list of
features but the main difference here
being did not include glove and these
this is these are good these are good
numbers here we're I'm delighted by them
and then yeah the less magnificant
magnificent magnificent systems you know
generally there was more exploration of
different modeling model types of some
people tried different you know neural
classifiers are different like an SVC or
something and generally just a very
short list of features and so in it was
it was fun to see in some of the top
systems how there was like tons and tons
of code trying all these different
models that was just ultimately
abandoned for the default model Factory
from the homework all in all loved
looking through the systems a lot of
creativity and I think we can all go to
sleep proud that we as a group have
managed to beat our baseline so it's so
resolutely so thanks for a really fun
Bay bake-off and you know one more to go
alright thank you oh yeah any questions
yes I'm sorry I do not have that offhand
it looks like it's probably about point
six five
although oh I see that's below 0.7 yeah
that's about this point six five oh so
the winning teams did really far about
that yes that's very yeah really that's
true
anything else all right
Oh get that baseline number line was a
lot higher higher ooh maybe I'm being
way too generous here that was I just
the number when I ran it so I guess I
maybe I should have done it more maybe
I'm I'm too optimistic okay we can check
that again so maybe maybe the big spike
here is right around the base line okay
that's me yeah all right good point I'll
run it again a couple times we'll see
where it shakes out
all right time for the real star of the
show all right Thank You Moritz that's
great and I guess it's worth pausing and
just saying
so bake-off four has been launched the
posters up on Piazza and I know a lot of
you have really invested in the systems
that you produce for these four Bake
off's and for people who did that I you
should feel proud I mean you've worked
out in a deep way on four very different
problems in NLU which is maybe four more
deep analyses than other courses offer
and I think that's a real accomplishment
right you've got real expertise now in
those four different problems and some
of you have done incredibly impressive
systems for multiple of these baked off
switch is again just a very impressive
accomplishment yeah so big off four is
up due Wednesday that's the final one
for us and then we'll move into a more
project oriented mode and I guess we'll
talk a lot more about that in the coming
weeks the the lit review after the
bake-off is the next thing that's due
that's due on May 13 and there are
guidelines at the website about what
that should contain we could look at
them now just in case there are any
questions actually that might be healthy
see
just so you know where they are and
everything so it's a short paper that
you can do in a group you should pick
one of the final project groups on
Piazza to do that so that credit gets
assigned in the way that you expect
groups of one should do five papers
groups of two should do seven groups of
three should do nine so that those
numbers there are kind of encouraging
you to work in a large group it's by no
means required but you have to do
overall less work in terms of reviewing
papers if you do that and not the other
thing I want to say here is just that
this is more than just a lit review so
it is also attempting to push you to
begin thinking about what problem you're
going to tackle and I will say that
given the time allotted the ideal thing
is that over the next week or so you and
your group just settle on a problem and
then go forth and do it changing in
midstream there just isn't a lot of time
to do that and I feel like that leaves
you behind so you should try to figure
things out now and then just go forward
with that plan and this is meant to sort
of encourage you to start that
problem-solving because we want you to
state for the papers that you chose what
their general problem is that's a good
creative active way of kind of
summarizing what you've studied you
should offer some concise summaries but
what you should really be doing there is
trying to tease out maybe the major
contributions and also getting to three
here like where these papers are alike
where they're different maybe where
they're starting to fall down or where
they've left gaps or where there's
obvious room for improvement maybe like
it's an older paper and you know about
some newer models that would be worth
trying on the tasks in which case that's
an obvious thing to point out because
that might start to point out the
outlines of the project you ultimately
want to do and as we say here this is
the most valuable this could be the
basis for the lit review section because
in the paper that you write for the lit
review section the goal there is not to
just rehearse what's been said but
rather to contextualize your work and
sort of justify the modeling choices
that you made and this compare and
contrast is going to lay the groundwork
for doing
I would say so that's the part that
you'll want to give real sought and then
obviously future work suggestions for
how these papers could be extended if
you do that in a thoughtful way then
it's an obvious discussion place for you
and your teaching team mentor because
your mentor can go in and say like
actually I think the first one is
resolved but the second one is
absolutely worth pursuing the third one
is maybe too hard so why don't you think
about to is kind of a guiding thesis for
your work on the project right that's an
incredibly productive thing that could
happen if you think really seriously
about kind of next steps for this and
then we also want you to have a proper
references section we're going to be
nitpicky about that you will lose some
credit if you don't have a proper
bibliography so just follow through on
that and again like that's going to
carry through all these assignments I
think it's just part of scholarship
we're not picky about the format for
this thing but we are picky that you
have a proper bibliography and that's
the spirit of this point five here so
think about this with your team get to
work on this as a document and do try to
use it as a chance to really lay the
groundwork for your project because then
you'll be off and running any questions
about that
good so after that the next document for
the final project is the experimental
protocol as we're calling it there are
also requirements for that I think I
won't review them right now except to
say that this is part of us kind of
pushing you in the direction of having a
quantitative analysis that uses data
that's a value that we've encoded in
this whole project structure and the
protocol is going to be a kind of check
in that your project will succeed in
that way and that you're also doing the
right things in terms of setting up
baselines and that you have the proper
metrics and things like that so once
you've done that I think you really have
like the foundation for your paper in
terms of its experiments and everything
and then the final things after that are
more presentational so a video and then
the final paper itself good okay
so I propose that we dive into the
material today we're going to talk about
grounded language understanding this is
like maybe my favorite topic for NLU and
this is kind of where we finally start
to realize what you might think of as
the true dream for NLU which is like
that you'd have a robot friend or
something and the reason I emphasize
grounding here is just because I do
think that if we're going to achieve
that goal of having robot friends
they're gonna have to exist in kind of
social physical environments in some
sense or at least be attuned to the fact
that humans live in such environments I
think they will not succeed if all they
have done is experience text flying
through them and maybe producing text
right and I'm gonna try to substantiate
that claim a little bit but I think it's
pretty intuitive that a big part of the
human experience with language but just
in general is being grounded in physical
and social situations and we leverage a
lot of that information and language use
production and understanding and so all
that brings me back to the fact that if
our systems are going to succeed then
they'll need to be grounded in these
ways and so what I've tried to do is
just assemble kind of the core building
blocks that I think you could
productively use to start to design
systems that are grounded and at the end
of the lecture I'm going to suggest some
ways in which even if you don't think of
your problem as a grounded NLU problem
there might be ways that you could bring
in some of that grounding and thereby
enrich your system in terms of its
performance but maybe also just in terms
of the rich ways that you could
conceptualize your problem and I've
framed this as a linguist would so I'm
going to give you some history and then
I'm going to talk about speakers those
are going to be agents that observe some
non linguistic thing and produce a
linguistic expression and then a
listener is an agent that consumes
language and makes an inference of some
kind about the world and then they come
together in chatbots
but the thing that I want to emphasize
there is that I think for a chatbot to
succeed again they need to be doing
something that's grounded in something
language external if they're just
talking back and forth at each other
with no purpose or goal they're not
going to succeed at doing anything like
what we want them to do so
emphasize grounding there and then
finally it gets most pragmatic when we
talk about reasoning about other minds
this would be how I could be more a more
effective user of language if I think
not just about production or
comprehension but also about what it's
like when I'm a speaker to be a listener
and when I'm a listener what it's like
to be a speaker and that can enrich the
system that you're using it can fill in
lots of the gaps in terms of the actual
sentence as we exchange with each other
and I think it keys it to something deep
about cognition but also about kind of
efficiently learning from data that's
another angle that I'm going to try to
convince you of when we talk about those
models and then finally just a
smattering of things that I didn't
really have time for but let's start
with some of this history this is a
slide idea that I stole from Andrew
McCallum and he just encourages us to
think maybe in 2019 now about the movie
2001 because you could think of that
movie as in part making predictions
about three things in terms of
technology first a prediction about what
graphics do computer graphics will be
like in the year 2001 about computer
chess playing in 2001 and finally about
NLU in 2001 because of the on-board
robot hal that is kind of the ship it
conducts very natural open-ended
conversations with humans and we could
think about what life is like for us so
let's do those comparisons for graphics
these are the graphics that they show
for Hal and in 1993 so even well before
2001 we had things like Jurassic Park so
this would be a case where the creators
of this movie just dramatically failed
to imagine how rich the future would be
right this is it's kind of a failure of
imagination that this is what computer
graphics would be like and this was the
reality in 1993 big gap we made a lot
more progress than expected I guess
for chess playing you could argue that
they got it exactly right so how the
onboard computer plays chess like an
expert and just before that in terms of
actual human history deep blue beat
Garry Kasparov in 1997 so that's pretty
impressive that
they more or less nailed the kind of
timeline in which computers would get
good at a game like chess
the third one dialogues have you've seen
the movie you can see that how has these
incredible human-like conversations with
humans and it's not just that it has
these conversations but that they are
obviously like deeply grounded in this
wrote this inhales plans and goals he's
in fact conspiring against them for his
own purposes and so forth but these are
incredibly rich interactions right by
2014 bill showed us what this would like
so this is the dream for Siri which is
already not quite approaching what how
can achieve but maybe at least I could
get my tacos ordered or something but
then bill showed us this funny skit from
Stephen Colbert which just showed the
gap between what Stanley Kubrick
imagined and what we actually realized
about I mean even more than a decade
after 2001 and that's sort of funny
because like if you compare you know
chess right in the middle but graphics
this failure to imagine and then when it
comes to NL you this kind of overstating
what we would actually achieve and I
think that comes back to the fact that
humans using language it feels
effortless it feels like something that
we ought to be able to master and in
fact like all throughout the history of
AI you have people stating that they're
just on the verge of solving all these
problems that they kind of see now that
it's the perceptron or you know computer
programming and scheme or now deep
learning these things are just about to
solve all these problems and they always
turn out to be elusive they always turn
out to be harder than we imagined
and I guess I'm going to try to
illuminate part of why that is I like
this quote from Terry Winograd that kind
of keys into this grounding ideal
language is action all language use can
be thought of as a way of activating
procedures within the hearer we can
think of an utterance as a program one
that indirectly causes a set of
operations to be carried out within the
hearers cognitive system it's kind of
nice and keys in to the goal-oriented
nature of this and also the social
component
also by way of conveying to you why this
problem is persistently more difficult
than people think I thought I would
present this analogy that I use when I
teach semantics and pragmatics as well
this comes from the linguist Steven
Levinson and he asked us to imagine you
know this there's a Rembrandt sketch
here and just observe for a second that
you can even if you've never seen it
before kind of make out that there's a
figure in the center there seemed to be
some people kneeling at the feet of this
this figure in the center there's an
archway or something some kind of
building is in the background and if you
have additional context for Rembrandt
sketches or for sketches like this you
could probably even make the inference
that this is a Christ figure in the
middle with disciples around right you
probably have other images in mind that
kind of resemble it that are more high
fidelity Levinson's point is that this
is incredible if you really look at this
sketch you start to realize that it is
just the barest outline of all of that
rich stuff that you were able to infer I
mean it is incredibly sketchy just at
some level of detail it's like a random
collection of lines but we are geared as
humans to be able to take those random
squiggles and infer all that richness
from it and you do it at kind of
multiple layers right so like even if
you don't have much context you can
infer that there's a figure if you have
additional social and cultural context
you can figure out that it's a Christ
figure and if you know something about
Rembrandt right this could get
arbitrarily deep because you when you
interpret that picture you're drawing on
much more than just the raw visual image
there you are able to imbue it with lots
of other information and that's a kind
of miracle about human vision and the
cognitive stuff that goes along with it
Levinson's point is that utterance
interpretation is very much like this
visual act when people speak to you you
are able to extract much more
information from their utterances then
seems to be encoded in those utterances
directly we do an incredible amount of
kind of what you might call reading
between the lines or figuring out from
somebody's very sketchy other
and the context you're in and the goals
you take them to have and what you know
about them as people you're able to
infer much more than what's just
directly encoded there and in fact it
might be that most of the information
that you extract is not coming directly
from what's encoded but rather from all
of that other stuff working in
conjunction with what what people
actually said to you just like here the
lines tell only this very small part of
the full story about what you extract
from the image and the naturalness of
what you do with the image is akin to
the naturalness of what you do when you
interpret people's utterances or when
you expect others to interpret your
utterances you don't reflect on all of
the gaps that people are filling in and
your apt then to underestimate just how
hard that is but when you confront NLU
problems you start to become aware very
quickly of just how much of this is
implicit and coming from context and
other side kind of like things that
aren't encoded in the language that we
use and I like this analogy a lot I mean
this is sort of like vision would be
really easy you know for robots if
everything had a barcode on it and
language understanding would be really
easy for artificial systems if
everything was limited to what's encoded
in the language that we actually utter
with each other the language itself
would be incredibly cumbersome but at
least it would be easy for machines just
like those barcodes but the reality is
that so much of it is coming from
elsewhere and that's why I think that in
the end for how to have a rich NLU agent
you're gonna have an agent that has lots
of other human-like capabilities let me
highlight a few of these things just a
kind of random collection of things that
I like from pragmatics that sort of
point at how hard this problem is going
to be so I'm starting with what linguist
called indexicality like I am speaking
the indexical here at least the obvious
one is the first-person pronoun I so you
might think that that's a pretty easy
problem to solve if you have some kind
of grounding I mean obviously if you've
just got text coming in and out then
figuring out what I means is the kind of
bizarre question even to ask but if you
think about today's
devices like your phone this is
something that you might have a pretty
sophisticated view of already like the
the phone could just at some level know
that the referent of I is the current
user or the owner of the phone or
something like that and that will be
correct a lot of the time already I
think that's pretty sophisticated but
that's just the easy case so what about
we won the meaning of we is constrained
probably to include the speaker but the
actual collection of people that it
refers to is incredibly context
dependent it could be a team I'm on it
could be a team I support it could be
the people in my community it could be
the people in my country right you just
this every way that you could possibly
imagine this going could be a meaning
for we so already when we move from
first to third person were confronted
with essentially all the problems of
pragmatics I am here maybe the AI is
easy but what about the here could be
the classroom could be Stanford it's
maybe not going to be interpreted as
planet Earth because that's not such an
informative thing to say in 2019 but
maybe someday I am here will be a
meaningful thing where here refers to
planet Earth
what about we are here pointing at a map
so that's an incredible kind of
abstraction that with a visual depiction
somebody can point and have that
transfer to the physical location and
that it doesn't mean that you're at the
point on the map I'm not here now this
is a wonderful example from linguistics
and philosophy of language but I'm not
sure that people use this anymore
because there are no landline phones and
therefore no answering machines but in
the old days your answering machine
might say I am NOT here now which is a
wonderful little puzzle because how
could it be that the current speaker is
not in the place that they are speaking
we went to a local bar after work this
has the challenges of we and I was just
highlighting here that adjectives like
local their interpretation is again like
here it's heavily context dependent and
highly variable in terms of exactly what
kind of thing it refers to
and there are lots of expressions like
this three days ago is indexical on the
time of utterance in terms of how many
days back you go tomorrow and now work
in a similar way and now of course has
all the uncertainty of here it's just in
the temporal domain so those are some
small words I think the only way that
you could get a grip on them in any
sense is with some grounding and then of
course you see that they have like
they're all the problems of pragmatics
writ small here are a few others context
dependence where are you from this is a
frustrating question for me I think
about this all the time because when
people ask me where I'm from I never
know what since they mean do they mean
Connecticut where I was born or the US
where I'm a citizen or Stanford which is
my affiliation or planet earth again
nobody asks that but maybe we'll live in
an exciting future where they do this is
coming from where and the reason I
highlight this example is it's a kind of
mundane question but already you can see
that it Keys into the goals that the
speaker has they're trying to figure out
something about you and the sense of the
question is determined by those goals
now those goals might be kind of under
determined I feel like when people ask
this they often don't know what kind of
information they're hoping to get back
and you have this awkward little dance
about whether you resolve their issue
that's an added layer of complexity on
top of the fact that to know what the
question means I have to know what your
goal is and that implies a sophisticated
kind of grounding here's some more I
didn't see any this is kind of keying in
to ellipses but also what linguists call
quantifier domains so are there typos in
my slides I didn't see any you might but
are there bookstores downtown I didn't
see any but they're cookies in the
cupboard I didn't see any right there's
no way I'm gonna get a grip on what this
utterance means unless I know at least
what the preceding discourse context is
but then you also have to do some really
sophisticated stuff about figuring out
how essentially to expand the meaning of
this elliptical phrase here any and that
again has two layers of complexity first
I have to figure out what thing you were
talking about but then I might also have
to do some
main restriction in the sense of like
when I say that everyone entered the
bake-off I don't mean everyone in the
universe
you guys effortlessly figure out that
when I say everyone in this context I
mean the students of cs2 too for you but
in a different context if I use it in my
house or in my department everyone takes
on a completely different sense the
light is on Chris must be in his office
the Dean passed a new rule Chris must be
in his office here showing that modal's
have a kind of sense ambiguity this one
is epistemic and this one is deontic so
this one is keying into knowledge and
here you're offering your evidence like
the light is on that's evidence that
he's in his office
this one is deontic in the sense that it
keys into laws of the campus in this
case and in this case this is the
relevant rule they have very different
senses this is pervasive in language
modal's exist not just as these
auxiliaries like must and may and can
and should but also in adverbs and
things like that and a big part of
figuring out what these statements mean
is figuring out the sense epistemic
deontic circumstantial there's lots of
different flavors and again we do this
without much reflection classic example
if kangaroos had no tails they would
fall over that probably seems true but
suppose they had jetpacks if I'm able to
insert that into the kind of implicit
counterfactual reasoning that goes into
this conditional here then it feels
false right they wouldn't fall over in
the worlds where they have jetpacks they
could just fly around somehow you know
not to consider that possibility until I
introduced it in which case maybe your
judgement about the truth of the
statement changes and that highlights
the flexibility of your reasoning in
these counterfactual situations and also
again the fact that you didn't really
reflect on it when I gave you the
initial example but it's certainly
important to be able to do that to
figure out what these claims are even
saying there's another example that I
love this is two books I think they're
real books what they teach you at
Harvard Business School what they don't
teach you at Harvard Business School and
then there's a masterful tweet the
two books contain the sum total of all
human knowledge a person is thinking
like a logician the actual sense of both
of these titles I guess is that there is
implicit domain restriction on these
what's here and so it's not this
knowledge and its complement in the full
space of all the things that could be
knowable but rather they both have taken
on a much more refined sense
perspectival expressions this is another
kind of grounding left and right front
and back former and ladder and I this
was a case where somebody's confused
about perspective this is from the
website you had one job please when
using the stairs stay to the right when
going up stay to the left when going
down this will keep people from running
into each other it will not and so here
just to kind of summarize this I have
this fairly mundane statement many
students met with me yesterday and in a
kind of informal way I just highlighted
all of the ways in which to understand
that expression you need some grounding
in the physical or the social context so
like how big is the set of students for
many students that's relevant what's the
time of utterance for understanding
these temporal expressions who's the
speaker for me what's the additional
contextual restriction on students which
might affect the domain of these
students here what's the time and then
you do other kind of things that we call
greicy and pragmatics like if you said
many students met with me does that mean
it's false that all our most did for the
constructive relevant set of students
and so forth and so on this is as I said
just completely pervasive any questions
about that before I switch gears a
little bit that's a quick run through my
greatest hits of phenomena in semantics
and pragmatics I could do that all day
if you want much more of that you could
take 1:30 a with me next winter if you
haven't already I know some familiar
faces here one thing I love about older
work in natural language understanding
is that it seems like they had full
we internalize this message that I just
sent about the importance of grounding
because from the beginning these systems
were grounded in in particular physical
spaces and like a really influential
paradigm case of this is Terry Winograd
shirred Lu system there's a youtube
video that kind of depicts what this was
like but basically it was a blocks world
in which things could be moved around
the blocks have colors so it's a very
finite domain and you could issue
instructions into this world and then
the blocks would be manipulated and the
the beauty of that first of all is just
that from the start these dialogues with
the system were fully grounded in that
visit in that world and then when you
look at actual examples of things that
the system could do you can see just how
much at some level the system was
leveraging the fact that it was grounded
in that space so like what does the box
contain the box is an expression that
you can only make sense of if you know
what environment you're in it that is if
you you and your listener can figure out
what the speaker's intended referent for
the box is the blue pyramid is the same
way what is the pyramid supported by
that's kind of in a four ik2 utterance
to there the box is the same boxes as
one how many blocks are not in the box
again that's an import that mate that's
a very difficult question to make sense
of unless you're grounded in an
environment four of them is referring
back to blocks system could do that the
red cube yeah all these things kind of I
mean the only way any system I think
could make sense of a dialog like this
and perform these actions and answer
these questions is if it was grounded in
a world like the one that Terry Winograd
had constructed and then there's another
contribution that Terry Winograd made
early on that I think still influences
how people think about NLU and these are
these sentences called wine a grad
sentences or schema sometimes
here's won the trophy doesn't fit into
the brown suitcase because it's too
small what is too small and you're able
to figure out that that means the
suitcase and the reason you're able to
do that is because you have an ability
to kind of simulate mentally what these
objects
like and how they're related to each
other which is coming from the fact that
you live in a physical world and you
have a lot of these experiences so
you're able to figure out that there
it's the suitcase whereas the trophy
doesn't fit into the brown suitcase
because it's too large what's too large
there you resolve to the trophy again
via the same kind of reasoning about
physical objects the council refused the
demonstrators a permit because they
feared violence who feared violence you
can figure out that it's the council and
you can do that because of your
understanding about social roles and
their relationships if I change it a
little bit the council refused the
demonstrators a permit because they
advocated violence who advocated
violence then your interpretation flips
to the demonstrators that first one is
very physical in its grounding and the
second one is grounded in more like
social constructs these are very
difficult problems I should have checked
on this but at least an as of recently
for the corpus of Winograd sentences
even very sophisticated deep learning
models were more or less performing at
chance then people worked really hard
and continue to work hard to kind of
construct systems that can solve these
problems I suspect that the real answer
will come from systems that have a whole
lot of really sophisticated and robust
kind of common-sense understanding about
the world and that it won't come from
just pattern matching on examples like
this and then finally another thing we
could do is just take our cue from
neighboring fields so for example
developmental psych is a field that is
all about how humans learn language at
least in part it's about how humans
learn language they have lots of lessons
about this and after all humans are our
best language learners by far in the
universe as far as we know kids can
learn word meanings for example with
incredible speed despite relatively
little input certainly nothing like the
amount of input that you would get for a
model that even models that you've
trained in this class how do they do it
the evidence suggests that they use
information that's inherent in the kind
of ways that forms contrast with each
other but also social cues assumptions
about the speaker's goal and
regularities in the physical environment
only this first
one is the sort of information that you
would get from looking just at for
example co-occurrence information these
other ones depend on grounding so some
consequences for NLU as I said human
children are by far the best agents at
learning language and they depend
heavily on grounding that's an important
clue for us problems that are
intractable without grounding are
solvable with the right kinds of
grounding you know the shirred luke case
is a dramatic example of that I think
you won't get traction on dialogues like
that reproducing them or understanding
them or anything unless you know about
the blocks world that they're describing
deep Lert then here's a bright spot for
this it's a real change over recent
years so deep learning systems there are
really flexible toolkits for reasoning
about lots of different kinds of
information in a single model and this
has I think led to some real
breakthroughs when it comes to grounding
because after all one way you could
think about grounding is I'm going to
have some vectors for my words but maybe
I'll also have vectors for the people in
my environment or the objects in my
environment or like a vector
representation of this image or this
video and these deep learning models are
happy to say I'll take your word
representations and your video
representations smush them together and
do something interesting and that's a
very productive way to think about how
you might gather a lot of evidence and
use it to make a decision which is more
or less than the lesson of this lecture
here so we should seek out datasets and
develop data sets that include the right
kind of grounding and this to the extent
that you can do that I think your system
will get better because at one level or
another all the language that we use
with each other is grounded
if only indirectly that's my pitch high
level description you also can edit like
the expose it with the edit the sort of
evaluations we're doing like even though
the whiner got schemas which seem like
they're getting at something very rich
about language they don't have a video
associated with them or like you know
here's the still of the picture that I'm
describing do you think that would be
something necessary in order to
go along with these datasets I think
that's in the spirit of what I'm saying
right which you so you could say I think
that no system is going to get traction
on your suitcase example with the trophy
unless I also show it lots of images of
suitcases and trophies and maybe their
physical relationships to each other and
maybe that's indirect about exactly what
we care about but maybe that's enough to
push the system in the right direction
and that would reinforce my narrative
which is it wasn't there in the language
but it might be there in this other kind
of representation I'm also reminded of
like it's related to things I've worked
on that kind of key into your intuition
so it would be very unusual for somebody
to describe the fact that the computer
in a room is on the desk because that's
the most mundane thing ever it's the
default assumption if I describe the
room to you I might not bother to
mention and I might just say there's a
computer and you'll infer that it's on a
desk or something and it's only if it's
on the floor that I would bother to
describe that so given that bias that I
have for describing things only things
that are unusual how will your system
ever learn the default stuff and one
might one answer might be that it can
consume visual representations and that
fills in all those gaps and things that
we never describe in language and
showing that would be wonderful
you somebody answered my question with
the later part explanation to answer but
I was thinking try to take away sort of
one level of indirection and also be
trying to fill up a lot so if you could
recognize that like a suitcase is an
object and that objects have size and
then try to sort of work out that
simulated model do the same thing great
example and so they're they're the
grounding in my terms might be a
knowledge graph that has all these
abilities information yeah and that
would get you over maybe the hurdle of
default things not being described yeah
great idea I'm gonna move on to these
speakers this is gonna get more
low-level now because partly what I want
to do is empower you to be able to do
some experiments and I also think
scientifically it's useful to start
small I mean those sure delude dialogues
are really ambitious we're probably
going to get more traction if we start
with things that are kind of more
controlled so that's the spirit of what
I'm going to talk about you'll see that
a lot of this is going to be about color
reference I forecasted this before I
chose color reference beat for a few
reasons so we have wonderful datasets
for this colors are great because it's a
an interesting kind of grounding you
don't have to deal with all the
complexity of visual scenes but colors
themselves are cognitively complex and
also pretty important to us and then the
language that you get for describing
colors is also quite rich especially if
you don't constrain people to a color
vocabulary so as a starting point
randall munroe the guy behind xkcd years
ago he did a color survey where he just
asked people to describe colors it's an
it's a massive dataset with millions of
instances of people describing color
patches here are some examples and they
go from the very simple things like
green and purple up top
grape which is a little more poetical
turquoise rarer then they get more
descriptive moss green light blue grey
robin's egg blue already some domain
knowledge creeping in British racing
green is not a phrase I'd ever heard
before
baby puke green is a classic example
from the Stata set there's lots of puke
colors in the data set that's the cutest
so this is kind of what I mean like we
have a wonderful playground of reference
these color patches
and then the language people produce in
response is also very colorful very
first model to think about here is my
most basic speaker and we're going to do
this in these kind of encode or decode
or neural frameworks that I'm sure you
guys have heard about this is a simple
version of models you might have seen so
down here I'm going to assume that what
comes in is like an RGB representation
of the color so just three floats
alright this one happens to be HSV I
think but some kind of color
representation comes in you might do
something to embed that color like some
kind of transformation of it to make it
higher dimensional or maybe more
cognitively interesting so that'll
happen and then you might map that into
a hidden representation which I'll call
the color representation there in orange
that's the encoder part this is a very
simple encoder which might be just kind
of a feed-forward model that produces
this hidden representation the decoder
part for our speakers is more
interesting so the way the decoding
works is we just assume they generate a
start symbol that's where they begin to
speak that gets an embedding
representation just like any other word
would and then you produce a hidden
representation which is a function of
the color representation and your word
rep so this is like where we've chained
them together with this red line these
two have to have the same dimensionality
because this color rep will be the
initial hidden state of the decoder this
is kind of the input and then the model
makes a prediction and what it does here
this is a kind of subtlety with what
I've written is dark it's making a
prediction that is a probability
distribution over the entire vocabulary
so this is a very high dimensional
probability distribution that's an idea
that can take some getting used to it's
a kind of miracle that this works
because it is a classifier but it's a
classifier into this incredibly high
dimensional space but things work out
all right that's where you get your
error signal so the truth in the data
might be that the first word is light
for this color that we're describing
down here and that that's a one hot
encoded vector and you get a standard
kind of error signal there here's a kind
of
so embedding derived representation
coming from these guys predicts a
distribution maybe like with a softmax
classifier and that gives you your error
signal here I've called this teacher
training at the top because even though
we produce the word dark the actual data
is light and so in teacher training here
we just make light the next word so that
is the input we look up it's embedding
we create a hidden representation from
h1 and x-37 they come in and then we
make another prediction blue and in this
case the error signal we did a good job
there and we continue so blue look up
it's embedding hidden representation we
predicted green but the actual thing to
do is to stop to produce produce this
stop signal so that's another error
signal for the model and in teacher
forcing the model will stop even though
it didn't produce the end token that
makes sense this is a generalization of
our model for nli right where you can
what we did for nli was just look at the
final output state that's where we get
our label here it's like we get a label
at every turn and then the other twist
which might take some getting used to is
this teacher forcing idea so that even
we though we made a wrong prediction
here we insert the correct prediction
down here in actual practice when you
train these models I guess best
practices is kind of to mix some teacher
forcing with some more exploratory work
where the model even though it really
like predicted the wrong thing here you
actually insert dark as the next word
and let it explore a wider part of the
space so that's how training works and
then at prediction time again a color
comes in that's what's given to us look
up its embed and get a representation
and then we have to just go on our own
here right so produce these predictions
and stop making predictions when we hit
the end symbol and in that case here we
produce this person description dark
blue does that make sense I don't know
how many of you has seen these models
before on the one hand it looks just
like the nli model on the other hand
when you think through
how training has to work and how
prediction have to work this is a bit of
a twist here the way you use the
predictions as inputs to the next step
but it is straightforward if you wanted
for example to implement this straight
forward to extend the PI torch and Ally
model to do this kind of thing in a
paper that I did with will Monroe and
Noah Goodman a few years ago we did
exactly this model using the xkcd data
set we did a Fourier transform to get
our initial representation here and then
another trick that we did is so that the
model wouldn't forget what color it
observed we appended the color
representation to all of the inputs so
that was kind of like at each token
remember that you're trying to describe
this particular color and I think that
helped it kind of be guided in the
expected way by this little bit of
grounding that we're giving it we wanted
a model that would describe colors and
then so this is another nice side effect
of working in a simple domain even
though this is a big crazy neural
language model we could actually get a
lot of analytic insights about what it
was doing by looking at its
representations in color space because
like we can give it as many colors as we
want and see what things it produces and
then we can look at the resulting
representations and you could see like
for example that it had learned that
greenish typically excludes green in a
kind of interesting way stuff like that
but fundamentally we just wanted a model
that would do multi-word color
expressions of the sort that are in the
data set images along with the captions
through something like this you get
contextualized we'd better it's kind of
like how working BEC doesn't
like it's there for you with us in a lie
you've got images you've got captions
yeah I'm surprised more hasn't been done
with it here's a small twist that brings
what is might be a more interesting
corpus so again with will and some
people here at Stanford Robert Hawkins
and Noah and and me we collected this
colors in context corpus so this one is
different in the sense that instead of
describing color patches in isolation
people were given three color patches
and told which one was their target to
describe to a listener and the idea was
that they succeeded to the extent that
the listener could figure out from the
same context which one was their target
so here you've got some you know a lot
of simple color expressions in these
very easy to distinguish contexts blue
purple green the person just said blue
but in this case here where there are
two blues they said the darker blue one
and I love that right because that's
grounding that comparative the darker
blue one is making implicit reference to
the fact that there are two very similar
color patches and it's picking the
darker one this is even more explicit
teal not the two there are more green so
these are all greenish colors and this
person was like very explicit about
picking out that one dull pink not the
super bright one not any of the regular
greens very rich context reference and
then I love these two so purple and blue
this is exactly the same color patch and
you can just see that depending on the
context they were in people describe
that color differently it's a classic
thing about colors that even your
perception of them can be somewhat
influenced by the competitors in the
space and here you see that reflected
linguistically and you can have a simple
speaker that does this I'm going to
return to this model but even this
baseline is interesting where you just
have it processed three color
descriptions embed them in the same
space you just designate that like maybe
the one closest to the end is the target
and then have it described and what you
get out of this model is color
descriptions that are implicitly context
sensitive
in the way that I just showed you we did
that same trick of reminding the thing
what the target referent was through its
training procedure and here are some
related ideas so you could think of what
I just showed you with color describing
as a special case of image captioning
which is a task I'm guessing you guys
have heard about it was revolutionized a
few years ago in part by researchers
here at Stanford by you know having
these captions be generated by a neural
encoder decoder for those models the
encoder part is typically much more
involved on one open to no one I just
showed you right all we had to do is
embed the color in some interesting
space but here we might have to embed an
arbitrarily complicated image but the
basic structure is the same you know do
some processing to your input object and
then produce some language and then
anticipating the colors in context thing
there were a couple papers from these
groups at Google that explored image
captioning as a kind of contextual task
so the intuition there is if you give me
three pictures of busses it's okay if I
say bus bus bus for my captions but what
you really might want there is captions
that distinguish the three buses so what
you want is a model that has some
incentive to say like school bus tourist
bus double-decker bus there's something
that is like that because of the context
and the confuse ability this pressure to
be informative in that context will lead
to more interesting captions and then
finally just kind of more open-ended
your visual question answering that's a
task where you're given an image and a
question text and together you have to
produce what I would call a grounded
answer to that question in the image
those are my speakers questions is there
any literature on like given an
utterance and
the read context say to choose the
context in which that others would have
been needed to distinguish between the
colors so not just the target but the
entire context I was just thinking
missed because I read the teal not the
two that are warm green and then I was
thinking okay which one of these would
uniquely be the one that was where that
would be necessary I don't know stuff
that's work on that but it's a very
interesting thing to think about
it's another perspective like you as a
human if I say the darker blue one you
learned that there are two bluish things
right and you're saying that for this
one you learned a whole lot about what
the whole context needed to be like just
because of presuppositions that you have
about the things speakers will do in
those contexts I love that yeah and
potentially you could use this corpus to
get some traction on that problem image
generation from the cache yes I have a
few reference those are what I would
fall under my listeners so I have a few
references for that too right image
shimmery yes yeah that would be like a
listener so for the listeners again you
could have the same data set people have
done this same task formulation will
have this colors and context thing
except now we're given the description
like light blue and this could be a
standard sort of RNN here and this will
be the crucial hidden state you might do
some transformations on that hidden
state to kind of move yourself into
color space and then what you're trying
to do is you're given this context and
it says one two and target so imagine
this one is the target here that's what
you want your agent to pick so you could
do some kind of transformation and work
that I've done we've done a Fourier
transformation to put these into a more
interesting space and then use this
hidden representation or some statistics
derive from it to create a score for
each of these elements of your context
and then those scores could be fed into
a softmax classifier that finally
decides based on all of this stuff which
of these things was actually the target
of the description so it's a little bit
more involved because of the structured
nature of the space
on the right how to be a listener here
but it's entirely doable and again
colors are cool because like you could
just make some simple assumptions about
what these representations should be
like to construct all the scoring stuff
and here are a few other things I other
ideas okay into your question so first
just first a framework here even a
simple classifier in my terms is a kind
of listener right at you consume some
language like a document or an Li
entailment pair or a sentence about a
movie and you make an inference into a
structured space and that's the kind of
simplest version of this and then the
other extreme I would say are the models
that bill is going to talk about on
Wednesday like semantic parsers where
you consume some language construct
maybe a very sophisticated latent
representation of that language and then
make a prediction into a highly
structured output space and then more
keyed into what I just showed you for
example is like scene generation so the
task of mapping from language to
structured representation of visual
scenes and here are some papers that do
this a common theme that runs through
them is what you actually do is map from
language into like an attribute value
structure of an image which then some
other process produces because you kind
of need some of these aspects of the
highly structured output space to get
traction but even that could be really
interesting like in this work with angel
Chang and colleagues we went from
language to attribute value descriptions
that could be fed into Pat Hanrahan's 3d
visual scene generator and then it could
produce these really rich visual scenes
and then this is another important paper
this is the image flickr 30k paper from
julia hawk and meyer and her group and
their idea was to learn visual
denotations for linguistic expressions
so one version of this of this problem
question yeah maybe the way you
mentioned this for the color a task is
that the speakers and the listeners are
sort of disconnected that we have no
data set of like
everyone says we're training a speaker
to kind of match those we also have this
at a veteran's colors and we're training
listeners to go from that to the
language to the colors but I feel like
there's also some research right on just
like end to end like a speaker is
generating a message that is directly
going to a listener that then needs to
try and recover the initial thing that
falls somewhere like I think that's next
right that would be like a chatbot I say
if I understand correctly if I don't if
the model you have in mind is different
from the one I show you just just ping
me again
but I think you're describing a chat
botton and my pitch here will be that
our chat bot should be grounded so
here's a standard kind of neural chat
bot setup where you have some agent say
what's up and it produces like hidden
representation then you have this bridge
into another R and the decoder and this
thing is tasked with producing
utterances and it does it in exactly the
way that my basic speakers did in the
color space right with the teacher
training and so forth so what's up not
much there's lots of work on this a lot
of it came out of Stanford I think a lot
of progress has been made on this
problem but I do think that you're kind
of fundamentally stuck if what your
model is doing is just reading in lots
of dialogue text and trying to mimic
what is in that text I think the lack of
grounding is always going to limit the
ability of these chat BOTS to do
interesting things especially did make a
lot of progress here like getting them
to be consistent in their utterances and
kind of getting them to produce
interesting dialogues so that they don't
degenerate into just saying I don't know
where I hate you which is a common
strategy for these things to fall into
and actually the one of the ways that he
overcame some of these limitations were
with what I would call grounding so for
example to enforce consistency so that
they wouldn't in one dialogue turn say
that they had children and then in the
next say they had no children he
actually created like user embeddings
for the different agents and that was
enough of an anchor to enforce a lot of
the consistency that he was after
but what I'm going to describe to you
here is an even richer form of grounding
this will be like task-oriented chatbot
and this is grounded in a really
wonderful couple of papers that came
from the facebook AI group the first
paper is called Deal or No Deal has
something that comes after that they
release a dataset of about six thousand
dialogues that are grounded in about
2,000 unique scenes this is the
interface the gist of this is that you
have two agents that are trying to
negotiate on a trade of some objects
these are the objects in this scene and
for this agent they've been valued
differently so the book has a value of
eight the hats have a value of one and
the balls have a value of zero so that's
the first thing and then each agent is
given a subset of them so this agent has
one book one hat and zero balls and the
agent that they're playing with has a
similar or may you know a different
value function and a different set of
the objects and the idea is that they
want to maximize the reward by via and
negotiation and it was nicely set up
because in every single scenario there's
a little bit of tension so it's not the
case that both of them can walk away
completely happy there has to be some
compromise and that's what leads to the
kind of interesting negotiation set up
here's what the data actually look like
it's kind of confusing li encoded for a
human but maybe easy for your neural
model so this is the representation for
there are two perspectives you and them
this is the you perspective and this
string of digits up here is saying that
you have one book worth zero for hats
worth two and one ball worth two and
then you get this little dialogue and
then the outcome so in the end after
this trade you have zero of item one
item zero sorry for of item one and zero
of item two then you get a little
boundary symbol and this encodes your
reward for this negotiation and whether
or not you agree to it and then finally
down here that's a representation of the
goal function for the other agent
these dialogues in the data set that
they released are all paired like this
so this was you perspective and here's
them it's the same dialogue but
different outcomes different goal
function and of course this was the U
one that I showed you before in orange
it's just been flipped so you get both
perspectives and the reason for that is
because of these different goal
functions the rewards are different and
even the agreement can be different that
makes sense anything I could clarify
about the task I think it's kind of
masterful and it's it's got some subtle
complexity that it generated really
interesting social dynamics I would say
here's their model oh go ahead I'll
double check it's all I can do to
remember the ordering of these things up
here that's why I put these reminders to
myself here's what their model looks
like they're obviously this is a huge
amount of information but I think at a
high level you can kind of get the gist
of what they're doing so it's a bunch of
RN ends they happen to use these gr use
so gated recurrent units could be LS TMS
they have a goal encoder that just
encodes in its own embedding space and
for its own hidden representations the
goal here like 1 0 4 to 1 you know
that's the goal sequence I showed you
before like object value object value
and then this is Hg this will be an
important state because you'll see it in
other places in the model but just
imagine that the agent has consumed that
goal representation and produced Hg then
you have a dialogue encoder and what
that thing is doing is just being a kind
of chat bot so producing language so
consuming and producing language and it
does that HG gets appended to all of
these tokens here again I think that's
just like the color thing it's a kind of
reminder about what the goal was in this
diffuse neural sense so it works like
a chatbot there and then finally for the
output encoder this is a kind of nested
thorn of a thorny nest of these
attention mechanisms I think I've
captured the gist of it so for the
output encoder here you notice that you
have H 1 X 1 H 2 X 2 that's the
conjunction of these representations
down here they produce their own
bi-directional RNN which is fed through
these attention mechanisms hg appears
again through the summary representative
concatenated with the summary
representation from all this attention
business and then that representation is
the basis for a bunch of different
classifiers item 0 1 & 2 predicting the
number of objects that were obtained
after this negotiation happened so
there's a lot going on here but the
high-level summary would be like a
neural encoding of your goal be a
dialogue agent and then a neural
classifier for the different output
states for the different items make
sense they do an interesting thing which
I'll return to but just at a high level
so the data set is kind of small so what
they do is they train two agents and
then fixed one fixed one and then
another agent can interact with that
first fixed one and start updating its
parameters here I've walked through that
so agent a that's the one we're training
it reads in the goal it writes out some
dialogue and then agent B this fixed one
responds because it hit this end token
here so the agent B produces some stuff
and that could continue these agents go
back and forth and then finally agent a
does this classification thing and gets
a reward and now you could do a
reinforcement learning thing of feeding
that reward back through the parameters
for a and in that way even without any
more human data potentially agent a
could get updated and maybe get better
at this negotiation task and here I mean
in principle agent B could be a human
helping to train this
system but I think they just used their
pre-trained one another really nice
insight from the paper is that even this
agent here is not especially well
grounded certainly this one is just kind
of operating in the world of language
and representations but it's not making
use of the reward here you see the
reward come in and then what they did is
this thing that they call dialogue
rollouts so in this case these agents
make predictions about how the
negotiation is going to go get a reward
signal and then that's fed back through
and it helps them make local decisions
in the way of like Markov decision
processes so like Here I am in my state
make predictions about the future get a
reward do that for a bunch of different
times and pick the the state transition
that is like the dialogue move that will
give me the highest expected reward from
this rollout and that's really nice
because then you're making very rich use
of the rewards for these local
negotiation decisions
that's my fast high-level summary I do
encourage you to look at the paper for
more details there's just one more thing
that's fun that I wanted to say about
this so there was an amusing media
narrative you guys might have heard
about this paper without even realizing
so far that you've heard about it so
this is the relevant passage during
reinforcement learning an agent a
attempts to improve its parameters from
conversations with another agent B well
the other agent B could be a human in
our experiments we used our fixed
supervised model that was trained to
imitate humans the second model is fixed
as we found that updating the parameters
of both agents led to divergence from
human language do you guys remember this
now ok so then they had a blog post
which is also pretty you know pretty
modest about this the second model is
fixed because the researchers found that
updating the parameters of both agents
led to divergence from human language as
the agents developed their own language
for negotiating okay so then Newsweek
the bots ran afoul of their Facebook
overlords and they started to make up
their own language to do things faster
not unlike the way football players have
shorthand names
certain place instead of taking the time
in the huddle to describe where everyone
should run I don't know about the
football analogy but at least the first
sight part of this is pretty clear
sighted it's not unusual for BOTS to
make up a lingo that humans can't
comprehend though it does stir worries
about these things that these things
might gossip about us behind our back
Facebook altered the code to make the
bot stick to plain English I think
that's still pretty good as a report
about what they did this next one is
different tech times Facebook was forced
to shut down one of its artificial
intelligence systems after researchers
discovered that had nots that it had
started communicating in a language they
could not understand and it gives
examples and the examples are like the
bots saying I'm me me me me me me me me
ball that's the language that they had
discovered on their own which I mean it
is kind of interesting to think that for
these agents that might be a meaningful
negotiation move and maybe you're
creeped out by that but I think this is
kind of overblown it doesn't stop there
the incident evokes images of the rise
of Skynet and the iconic Terminator
series perhaps Tesla CEO Elon Musk is
right about AI being the biggest risk we
face I mean you've seen the model I
think this is a bit overblown back down
to earth if you're interested in these
problems here's a bunch of other
datasets some of these are pretty hard
but there are also instances of doing
task oriented dialogue and I think you
could have a lot of fun exploring with
them
okay last phase of what I wanted to do I
can at least give you a flavor for this
this is what I've called reasoning about
other Minds here's my little motivating
example which will remind you of Grice
if you've read Grice so they have these
two agents here and just imagine that
they're referring to these two cylinders
so this agent is going to say the blue
one please and it has in mind this one
on the left this agent the idea is that
this agent is thinking my listener knows
that I'm cooperative in the gricean
sense and what that really means is just
that I'm trying to communicate in an
open and honest way and my listener
knows that and we kind of collectively
know that both of
can leverage information about the
context and what we know about being
human and so forth in order to figure
out what we mean so they'll be able to
work out that I mean the unmarked blue
one the idea there is that since you
just said blue and not something like
baby blue that it must be the unmarked
form of blue and then if you're the
listener you think wait a second the
blue one that's ambiguous but I was
assuming that the speaker was
cooperative that's this kind of
collective social thing ah but if I
assume that they have would have picked
a marked form like baby blue if it were
true then it must be that they mean the
unmarked form like if they had could
have been more informative in that way
with their utterance they would have
been and they weren't so I'll default to
assuming they mean the unmarked one and
in that way they get this kind of mind
meld around this one and the idea is
that this would be completely different
in this context the blue one this is the
same color blue that I had over on the
right here but now the blue one would
just obviously refer to this one no
confusion so that's the kind of dynamic
that we're trying to capture all these
thought bubbles the idea is that if our
systems could do this at some level then
they would be more efficient in
communication here's a simple model for
doing that it's called the rational
speech X model it was developed by
people here at Stanford and it has a
kind of hierarchy of three probabilistic
agents so the literal listener here
observes a message this is like the
listeners I showed you and we're
assuming some language that they speak
Lex and on the basis of that message in
that language makes a guess about what
the world is like and they do that based
on a prior over the world PW and also
just this core lexical information which
you could think of as kind of just your
knowledge of the language that you speak
so that's the literal listener the
pragmatic part about this is that we
have a pragmatic speaker now speakers in
this model observe the world and the
language and then they produce a message
just like the speakers that I showed you
before and the idea is that this speaker
does this based on the literal listener
that's the purple here and some
information about how costly different
messages are how marked they are
something but the important thing here
is that the speaker is not just
reasoning directly about the language
this Lex but rather about a listener
literal listener of reasons about the
language so that's that one layer of
indirection and already there you get a
richer communication system than you
would have had if you were just
reasoning about the language and then
finally this pragmatic listener here you
have two layers of indirection so it's a
listener it observes a message and makes
a guess about the world but it does it
by reasoning about the prior over worlds
and the speaker whose reasoning about
the literal Lotus literal listener this
back and forth is kind of mirroring
those thought bubbles where it was like
I'm a listener and I imagine I'm a
speaker oh and then I can work it out or
on the speaker side as well you can
reorient this model however you like the
important thing here is that if you're a
pragmatic listener or a pragmatic
speaker you don't reason just about the
conventions of your language you reason
about agents who are using those
conventions and from that you get
additional meaning here's a simple
example
so I have just a very simple case here
we have two messages beard and glasses
this is David Lewis with his magnificent
beard he was a philosopher and this is
Paul Grice he doesn't have a magnificent
beard at this time in his life but they
both have glasses so true true true
false at this level if you were a
listener and you heard beard or glasses
beard would be unambiguous for you right
away
but glasses is true of both these
entities so if you heard it you would
have to make just a random guess about
which of these two entities the speaker
was referring to if you were a kind of
mechanical semantic listener if I
perform that speaker calculation that
speaker agent that I just showed you
already now surprisingly I have an
unambiguous system if I want to refer to
Louis I'll probably say beard and that
follows from the fact that if I want to
refer to Paul Grice down here my only
option in this constraint signaling
system is glasses and that creates this
kind of separation and then when we go
one layer further
now beard that unambiguously refers to
Lois because grace doesn't have a beard
but notice that that 50/50 is now twenty
five seventy five a lot of bias in favor
of hearing glasses and thinking its
grace and that is just like that dynamic
I showed you before where you kind of
were literally just mathematize
if I wanted to refer to Lois I could
have done it with beard and since I
didn't you must mean classes you must
mean grace and the model has more or
less just turned that into a little
probability a Bayesian model of that
reasoning that's a wonderful model it's
been incredibly successful in
linguistics and psychology
lots of good experimental evidence that
people are doing something like this
calculation I think a lot of problems
and pragmatics were solved quite neatly
by this model but if you want to think
like a computer scientist it's pretty
limited because in all that work you
have a hand specified lexicon and then
when you perform that speaker
calculation if you take the model
literally you have to reason about every
possible alternative message they could
have produced which for a language like
English is not even a finite number of
things presumably and then it's a very
high bias model because I hand specify
this and there's no learning I don't
have many chances to learn that for
example people love to say beard for
David Lewis because his beard is so
visually salient the colors in context
corpus is a setting in which we can
think about this as a machine learning
problem it's too large for a hand
specified lexicon but maybe we can think
about the speakers and listeners I
showed you before and whether they could
solve this problem so here's how this
might go the literal neural speaker is
the one I showed you before let's call
that s zero it just produces the context
sorry consumes the context and produces
a description presumably of the target
here the neural literal listener is the
one that I showed you before it consumes
language and together with the context
makes a guess about what the referent
was in that context
those are the literal agents the ones
that we would have hand specified in the
previous mold now we just have these
kind of blackbox neural models doing
this work for us and then in the
simplest version of this model you could
just apply that RSA calculation on top
of those two agents so here's the
speaker it's going to depend on that
literal listener which is the neural
listener I showed you and this is kind
of cool instead of having to worry about
all the conceivable utterances that are
alternatives to want the one that was
chosen you could just sample from that
speaker and use that as an approximation
of this denominator here once you've
done that your problem is solved the
pragmatic listener is just an
application of the RSA calculation on
top of this s1 here so in that way
you've got these pre trained models
they're done you apply the RSA
calculation and presumably those agents
can do better at this task because
they're effectively reasoning about each
other and I'm running out of time here
but I wanted to mention also that
another way of solving this problem here
is to just change the space of atomic
messages and that's what my student did
so he did what we call pragmatic image
captioning which is like that work I
mentioned from the Google Groups before
and here he applied RSA to a standard
image captioning system and he actually
instead of sampling from s 0 reasons
that applies the RSA reasoning step at
the level of individual characters and
shows that that leads to better and more
informative captions in these contexts
than alternative simpler models and
that's like a wonderful instantiation of
this idea this intuition that for
informative image captions I should be
thinking about the context I'm in and
trying to produce a caption that is
distinguishing my target from the rest
and here's a bunch of other work some of
it with different kinds of corpora
associated with it some of it from
robotics some of it from semantic
parsing lots of data sets some newer
developments down here that you might
want to pursue I think this is a very
exciting space and then here are a few
other corpora
tuna is a classic one that's like those
philosophers I showed you I don't ask me
why it's called - and I can never
remember Scone is a newer one from
Stanford and then Robert Hawkins
actually released a crowdsourcing engine
that would allow you to collect your own
reference games if you want to do for
this final step here I just wanted to
gesture at a few ideas I know we're out
of time so I won't go through them in
detail but like here's just again the
simplest case of this sarcasm detection
there's a wonderful corpus for this
called Sark sarcasm is a classic case of
a problem that you will not solve with
looking at text alone it is not a fact
about a statement like great idea that
it is sarcastic or not it is sarcastic
when used by certain people in certain
contexts and this Sark corpus is a
derived from reddit it's an opportunity
there because you could learn user
embeddings form embeddings immediate
dialogue context embeddings and show
that all of those things are influencing
the decision about whether an utterance
like great idea is sarcastic or not and
in this deep learning mode that's easy
just add more representations into your
model and see if you can learn them
effectively and then I pointed out a few
other cases this is an example where you
could do something similar but in the
context of social graphs which would be
another kind of grounding kind of keying
into your intuition earlier about
knowledge graphs plough this is
wonderful work from James Allen where
the context that you're in is a webpage
which is very highly structured it's
just another way to think about how you
could get beyond the limitations of
language by actually having a rich
representation of the context here it's
more symbolic but there are lots of web
pages out there so there's no shortage
of these structured contexts and then
here's some work that I did with Adam
Vogel that is more in the mold of like
old-style
decision process models and here I just
wanted to point out this is this is just
wonderful so just give me one minute so
we had these agents play this
collaborative game where the their goal
it's kind of hard to see but their goal
was to just be co-located with this card
here they succeeded if they both found
it in some sense and they could
communicate
and we didn't card code anything about
their incentives to actually communicate
we just said you have this ability to
understand language if it comes in and
to produce it if you wish we're speaking
was an action just like moving around in
the board was essentially and these
agents get trained over a long period
after just a few hours of policy
exploration which is like training for
these models they would do funny things
like this agent found the card but what
it said was top and that sent the other
agent off toward the top you can see it
has a high probability for thinking that
the card is at the top it's a very bad
state for them to be in they learn
pretty quickly from this kind of
grounding together with their reward
function that they should not use
misleading language so after a few week
of policy exploration now they produce
true utterances and about that same time
they realized that it there's a reason
for them to produce utterances because
if they do they can quickly influence
the actions of the other agent and they
solve the problem quickly and since
these agents are set up where every
moment for them is misery all they want
to do is find this card so that they're
freed from these this misery they pretty
quickly learned that they should produce
utterances and actually true utterances
and that's a kind of gray scene thing
that we claimed was emerging from their
grounding in this particular goal in
this particular environment I thought
that was very exciting the problem with
these models is that they're really
intractable and I think they're just
waiting for you know the day when they
get replaced by neural approximations
which might be less crisp in terms of
what they learn for policies but more
able to deal with changing environments
and complicated environments and so
forth here I think that kind of keeps me
up for these next frontiers here so what
I expect is much deeper integration with
devices and the environment more
sophisticated reasoning about goals
better tracking of dialogue history and
as I said just now approximant state
state representations to address these
scalability issues I think progress here
is going to lead us to agents that are
truly grounded and that will lead us to
agents that are truly able to use
language in a sophisticated way ok that